and most of all while I've got your
attention I love you guys thanks for all
the love this Instagram storm over the
last 10 14 days it's been a whole lot of
fun he's brought a lot to me as much to
me as it has for you oh and look signed
the [ __ ] little books
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I told you this was last Monday morning
a delight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right Claire it's coming Claire
one egg Kyle Alex Peter it's fun the the
one of the biggest reasons a lot of
people a lot of people don't do things
for the community like engage or reply
or make videos and reply or do giveaways
wave the sign stuff or two and three
minute meetings at 15-minute meetings
via FaceTime or shadow for the day
reason I people don't do that is because
it takes up time I just landed from LA
I've got a lot of work done and which
set up another five to six things that I
have to take care of right now and she's
gonna eat into those ten minutes that I
just don't have and I need him and I I'm
okay with that because I believe in it
and it's what I want to do and it's how
I give back to you guys for your
attention and that's the value exchange
I'm cool with it
but boy do most people not want to go
there
most people don't like the process they
just want what's on the other side of it
and especially when they make it they
kind of want to reap the benefits the
thing for me is I'll never make it
it's always gonna be a journey right
I mean first and foremost I created a
ridiculous journey I love how people
don't really understand how all-time
wealthy you have to be just to buy a
football team so I put myself in the
corner trying to create
one of those situations and then I went
about it in a very tried-and-true way
which means for me by my definition that
I are trying to not only revive the New
York Jets you mean I'd have to become a
billionaire which is very difficult I'm
doing it while I in parallel give back
unlike a lot of executives and CEOs and
entrepreneurs they put 100% of their
efforts towards their goal they punt
everything else they do not give back to
the entrepreneurial community did not
give back to the individuals in the
world and through this new technology
has happened so the Titans the Mavericks
she didn't have time and more
importantly she didn't have technology
in 1950 to document like this 1960
document like this 1970 document like
this 1982 document like this 1992
document like this
Boyd you got your book and so that's uh
that's what happened right so what I'm
trying to do is really difficult in my
mind and I enjoyed it or that which is
giving back along the way while trying
to achieve something ridiculous which it
is battling on two fronts which is very
difficult and that's fine by me because
truth is I wouldn't have it any other
way
I don't want
the New York Jets if I don't also show
the blueprint for the next guy and girl
who want their New York Jets I don't
want it if I don't give back to the game
that's given me so much opportunity and
so documenting this journey of building
a honey Empire of building the cleanest
and the best and not most passionate but
truest community of anybody online right
now that's a big ambition of mine
because I know I have an advantage for
me that's a foregone conclusion because
I want so little in return I I know that
I'm giving away a lot more than I'm
asking for in return because when you're
not asking for anything you're in a very
very very good spot to me your attention
and you picking me is more than enough I
do not need to make $86 a piece off of
you in a ebook I don't need to sign you
up
for eight $20,000 a month mastermind I
do not need those things and so
that is how I am going go it d-roc
vaynernation and gordon get the last one
that's not true perfect thank you cut
you know what so symbolic that this was
at the bottom I love it this makes me so
happy most underrated book that I've
written least selling book of the four
business books and the one that is so so
tried and true to what I'm actually
doing here and so thank you and thank
you John
and back to the grind
what you guys doing like registration or
something I can't believe I was able to
figure that out just from the little
pump that'll gave out
I'm literally one of the smartest people
on earth and what a smartest people on
earth
where's my photos India's live
she's a Gary Vee here influencer it's me
she goes it's not no it's me
Indians always me she's like I don't
think it's Gary you know she's like
literally is one of the few people on
earth that knows it is me get a caller
of course it's me you're one of the few
people on earth that knows it - me too -
okay all right see you
all fears that's what he wants no shock
did you know that I hate Paul Pierce
that you could tell him right now
literally he could have said that's
insane that he said that he literally
literally could have said anybody
anybody Larry Bird he could have said I
don't know Sherman Douglas he could have
said anybody Chauncey Billups who played
for them for four minutes Antoine Walker
he could have said anybody but Paul
Pierce I hate Paul Pierce tell him tell
him tell him actually G Rock will give
you this clip just tell him you blew it
Wow Wow
great to be back in New York I can feel
it right away it's in my blood I love it
it's a totally different vibe
I'm also really getting back into the
mindset of not filming which is good
really enjoyed last week and a half of
an enormous time to engage with fans
especially through Instagram with all
their new features so that was fun
football season's over going to honor AJ
tonight at a foundation which I'm
excited about and and moving forward
moving forward and getting ready to go
away this weekend for two weeks
that's that time of year we're debating
a lot here about what we're gonna do
because it's really it's truly the time
when I want to be checked out and we've
made this commitment to dailyvee I don't
know we'll see debating
off to AJ's event just have a nice
meeting Vayner sports will affect some
good vaynermedia calls living
[Music]
[Music]